boyle what are those my guinea pigs this
lady is claire
and this guy is also named claire you
can't have pets in here this is a police
precinct
i know i'm sorry i got them for
nikolaj's birthday but it turns out he's
allergic and the pet store won't take
them back i got a friend who works in a
lab
i can call and see if they need any
guinea pigs for their research they are
not science experiments they are living
creatures with rich
inner lives claire number two is stuck
on his back like a bug oh i'll handle
this
i flipped the wrong clear stop flipping
guinea pigs and get them out of here
i'll make them disappear lieutenant oh
don't kill them they have so much to
live for they haven't even been to
manhattan yet okay coast is clear i know
a safe place we can hide these guys
until we can find homes for them you're
not gonna murder them hell no
i love animals i'm the mushy one on the
squad right of course
this is a supply closet cave it's full
of cpr training babies no one goes in
there cause it's too creepy
oh my god it's perfect oh hey boyle do
you have the six street case files
wait what's that uh this it's
my water bottle it looks like a water
bottle from a guinea pig cage
a true i got it for the guinea pigs but
they're not here anymore so i decided to
be green and use it for myself
ah first quenched what took you so long
terry almost caught me i had a drink
from the guinea pig's water bottle
amazingly he totally bought you do that
mm-hmm yeah i'm not surprised at all
good news my niece will take the two
clairs she wants them as pets that is
great okay now we just need to find a
home for ten more
ten boy claire got girl claire pregnant
made a bunch of little baby claires oh
they're having sex again
oh claire oh claire claire claire hey
rosa good news
i just talked to someone who said he'd
take all of the guinea pigs
all 600 why would he do that i didn't
ask i just said yes our prayers have
been answered who is this guy we gotta
check him out make sure he's not weird
he's just a normal guy who's a friend of
hitchcock's
yup we gotta check him out
yeah he's gonna turn him into cheapest
oh my god he is
someone's here this is too public i mean
it wouldn't stop hitchcock but
fine i know a secret spot
um oh what was that
what am i feeling right now huh are
those all your tiny little hands
and this is the last one we've rounded
up all the guinea pigs
not even close guinea pig guinea pig
guinea pig guinea pig
guinea pig what were you thinking
breeding guinea pigs at work we weren't
breeding them on purpose they're just
very sexual creatures and we didn't want
to slut-shame them yeah
sorry you're not more sex-positive terry
i called my friend at the lab he's gonna
take the guinea pigs they're not gonna
do any chemical tests on them they're
just gonna teach them how to run mazes
really
i want you to look claire 38 in the eye
and tell her that i'm sending you to the
lab claire
bye you can't do this it's so unfair
terry you're a cruel man
thank god i found a way to end it's over
you